- [Voiceover] This is Charlotte,
a prehensile-tailed porcupine.
With her short, thick spines,
she's adorably speckled,
but that cute little outfit
is actually an excellent
defense mechanism.
Her spines rise up when threatened
to give a larger and more
threatening appearance.
Charlotte will spend most
of her life in the trees
deep in the forests of
Central and South America.
She feeds on bark,
leaves, fruits and roots.
Her feet have long, curved claws,
making her an adept climber.
While prehensile-tailed porcupines
are formidable at protecting themselves,
they are less successful against humans
as they are hunted for food
in parts of their habitat.
That along with a diminishing territory
have left their population in flux.
This is the prehensile-tailed porcupine.